حكومه لبنان اصدرت اول مؤشرا متعدد
الابعاد للفقره تتوزع هذه الابعاد على
التعليم والصحه الرفاه المالي والبنيه
التحتيه الاساسيه والمستويات المعيشيه لكن
كيف يعشها اللبنانيون الكهرباء مثلا كبوس
يعيشه اللبنانيون يوميا توفر الحكومه
حاليا الكهرباء فقط لمده تتراوح بين ساعه
وثلاث ساعات في المتوسط بينما يسد الاشخاص
القادرون على دفع تكاليف اضافيه نقصت
تغذيه الكهربائيه بمولدات خاصه ولهذا
تكلفه اضافيه ليس بمقدور الجميع ان
يتحملها تساهم ازمه الكهرباء في تفاقم عدم
المساواه ودفع الناس الى الفقر كيف تكلفه
الكهرباء اثرت على قدره الاسر على دفع
تكاليف الخدمات الاساسيه الاخرى في قطاع
اخر تطال الازمه المستفحله المرضى
فالحكومه خفضت اجمالي انفاقها في القطاع
الصحي بالنسبه 40 بين عامي 2018 و2022 كما
ان هناك نقصان حادا في الادويه اذا رفعت
الحكومه الدعم عن ادويه
والمستوردون عجزون عن استيراد الادويه
بسبب الازمه الماليه يبدو ان لبنان يتجه
نحو سياسه الدوله على امل تحقيق الاستقرار
في الاقتصاد التعامل بالدولار لكن ليس
الكل قادر على الدفع بالدولار معضله اخرى
تعمق الفقر في البلاد نقص العمله في
البنوك والحد من عمليات السحب ضياع مدخرات
الكثير من الناس
الاسبوع الاول من شهر مارس وفيما يشير
اختصاصي وعلم النفس الا ان الازمات
الاقتصاديه لا يمكن ان تؤدي الى الانتحار
الا انها السبب الاساسيه لتازم الصحه
النفسيه لللبنانيه ومع الانهيار المستمر
لقيمه الرواتب بالليره اللبنانيه غادر عدد
كبير من اللبنانيين الطبقه الوسطى باتجاه
الطبقه الفقيره وبحسب المعايير الدوليه
فان خمسه وثمانين بالمئه من اللبنانيين
يعانون من فقر متعدد الابعاد اما المعايير
المحليه فتشير الى ان خمسه وخمسين بالمئه
منهم غير قادرين حتى على اشباع حاجاتهم
الغذائيه الازمه دخلت عامها الرابع ازدادت
معها معدلات المطاله والتفكك الاسري
وحالات الانتحار وفقدت القطاعات التربويه
والاستشفائيه صنعتها الطيبه
نحن صايمين صويمينا تعرف شو الواحد عم
يقرا بالنهار مستشفى الحكومه شفتها حكومه
16 مليون لبناني و160 دولار عندي اربع
اولاد لله ما فينا
لانه اذا بدك توديهم الاوتوكار على كل ولد
بده 20 دولار ودولار ما بياخذ لبنان الا
دولار